OK, cool.
Um, let's get started.
So H2AI,
um, HOAI basically is a global
leader in the enterprise AI realm.
H2AI does both
generative and and predictive
AI. And the
Have an entire platform which
we are able to install in on-prem environments,
in clouds, and in air gapped
environments.
H2AI is a leader
in
um
the Gaia benchmark,
and we deliver
an entire platform.
Um, So
our technology stack,
basically our entire platform runs entirely
on Kubernetes.
Everything runs in EKS in the cloud,
and we rely very heavily on
EBS storage.
The reason we rely on EBS storage is when
we train data
and we we train our models, we need very
fast and
um good storage for our AI
engines. The
problem that we had with H2AI with
EBS storage
is that we had a lot of
unutilized storage.
Basically we were storing over 2 petabytes
of storage and it was growing very
quickly
and the issue is that we couldn't scale very good.
We couldn't scale down,
we couldn't be more efficient with our cloud storage,
and
we ended up wasting a lot
of storage in the cloud.
We looked at this
issue and we tried to find
several solutions.
Most of the solutions that we found out there
were solutions that required us to migrate
data
from old EBS storages to
new EBS volumes,
so basically it was a very hard and
painful
um process
and um that was the
issue that we had previously before we started
working with Dattafi.
Thanks Ophira.
So when we met H2O initially, we were
very pleasantly surprised because the problems
that Ophira has described are exactly
what we set out to solve with Datafi
large EBS capacity,
overprovisioned and underutilized.
Datafi is an autonomous storage
solution
which manages cloud storage
automatically, autonomously
for AWS customers.
You can deploy it on the fly and
it will adjust your volume capacity in
EBS automatically,
auto scaling it based on your needs.
If you fill it up, it will grow automatically,
and if you delete files, it will shrink
it automatically.
It has no impact to performance. You can
deploy it in real time.
With Datai
you get dynamic auto scaling,
so the solution is completely autonomous
and it overcomes those EBS limitations
that Air mentioned that prevented him
from being efficient in his consumption
of EBS.
It allows to basically endlessly
scale your EBS capacity both
up and down as customers
fill up data and delete and enter
these cycles of growth and deletion.
Whenever you use data file, there's no downtime
at all. We've always thought that customers
will not tolerate introducing downtime
to their applications when they want
to improve their storage utilization.
You can install it or uninstall it without
any impact to applications,
to your file system, or to any other
thing running in your stack.
Furthermore, there's no changes needed
to your stack.
It integrates seamlessly with Kubertis,
with cloud formation,
with Terraform,
and it supports any Linux operating
system
and any tech stack you're running on top of it.
So you don't need to inform your customers,
oh, we're going to take down time because we want to do
something with the storage.
The whole thing is done automatically and
seamlessly
without any intervention required by you
or your application owners.
So how does Data fight work?
It is based on a low level agent
that you install
on your EC2 servers or you recupernate
these clusters.
This agent changes the
destination volumes of EBS
automatically and dynamically without
impacting your applications.
In addition to that, we have a SAS control
plane or. A back end that runs in RVPC,
it monitors the agents and it
gives them commands like growing volumes
or shrinking volumes.
It also
provides analytics and shows
you what exactly is going on with your EBS
deployments,
how much storage you're consuming, how efficient
are you, how much efficiency Datafi brought to the table.
Finally, we've spent a lot of effort
into integrating with infrastructurist code
environments, both Kubernetes
and other infrastructurist code environments.
This allows you to use
the product without making any modifications
and it completely uh
uh integrates into the life
cycle of CICD.
So along the way when we started
working with Dattaify we had a couple of issues
and we had a couple of challenges that we needed to
solve in order to
streamline the entire process and make sure
everything works with our existing platform.
The first thing that we had a challenge with was bottle
Rocket.
So together with Dattaify we worked together and
we made sure that the Dataify agent
basically runs on our existing bottle rocket
infrastructure that we have in EKS.
The second thing that we
had, the second challenge that we had was
security. Basically as an AI platform
we host our customers' data
and we wanted to make sure that
working with Dataify everything is just
as secure as it was previously.
And the main part here was with Dataify
that no data leaves
the actual cluster,
no data leaves the EKS,
and
the task thativan talked about is
only management,
so we keep.
The same level of security
and the same level of reliability for our customers'
data. The last challenge
that we had with um with working
with Datafi is basically
keeping our existing
backup implementation
so we have a solution that
we work with with Vallevo
to make backups send to backup PVs
and together with Datafi we made sure that
we're able to to continue using
the existing solution
with Vallejo.
And seamlessly
continue to back up and restore dated
volumes without any, any issues.
So we thought it would be nice to show you an example
of the kind of optimization that Data I
brought to H2O.
On the left side chart, you see
the capacity utilization.
Customers typically have low
capacity utilization, especially on EBS.
They tend to overprovision because they're
afraid they're going to run out of space, and
they're afraid they're not going to be able to grow in time.
So on the left side.
The beginning of the chart, you see that the capacity
utilization is just 25%,
which means that they're overpaying
4x
compared to if they could have paid
based on utilization
rather than capacity reservation
as EBS charges them today.
As they deploy data on more
and more environments,
the chart for utilization keeps
growing and improving
to the point where it stabilizes
around 80%,
which is our natural
place where we want to hold the buffer. We don't want to
make it
hit 100% because that means we're
running out of space.
So it's quite typical to stabilize
around 80%, which is what we consider
success criteria.
On the right chart you can see what's happening
in terms of the capacity
itself. When we started out, their
total capacity footprint was about
2 petabytes,
but in terms of how much data they've
actually written to it,
the green line shows you only 0.5
petabyte written.
That's why we say the capacity utilization is 25%.
As time progressed with the utilization
of Dafi,
what you're seeing is really interesting. Even though
the green line grows a bit because
they wrote more data,
the blue line, which is how much capacity
they're paying for an EBS,
keeps dropping
because of the data file or scale capacity.
A long time, the blue line
almost reaches the green line, which is the 80%
utilization that we were targeting.
The savings for H2O
are not paying for 2 petabytes,
but actually paying for
less than 1 petabyte,
and that's significant savings, and this
is applicable
for just about any EBS customer
out there.
So basically the
result of our work with Dattaify
was that we were able to deploy the
Dataify solution across all our customers.
The Dataify solution is deployed with our existing tools
and solutions,
meaning that we still use Terrafone to deploy,
um, DataF.
It's, it's integrated into our GitOps
process, and we didn't have to make
any substantial changes to our
infrastructure to get Datafi to work.
Of course we have a very big um cost
saving which Devan just showed
um
we were able to.
Take up our utilization and reduce our
cost.
While we're we're doing that, we were also
able to give better performance to our customers.
So basically the, the data 5 solution
was able to reduce
our cost for EBS and
also increase our performance for our
EBS volumes.
And I think that the most important part of
this solution, the data file solution,
is that there was zero downtime.
So once the data file agent was
deployed and was in all the clusters
in a read-only mode,
we just had to flip a switch
and basically from that point on it
started doing its magic.
Basically reducing our storage
without any manual intervention
that we had to do.
So just,
again, on the flip of a switch,
we started seeing reduced um storage
costs.
Thank you, thank you very much.